[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lovell
cable news networks across the board are
hemorrhaging viewers the political left
hated and still hates donald trump but
cable news
did well during his time in office it
was politics as spectacle and profitable
how much longer can cable news networks
remain relevant
[Music]
across talking mass media i'm joined by
my guest rob taub in new york he's a
writer as well as a television and radio
pundit
also in new york we have steve malzberg
he is the host of eat the press at rt
america
and in montreal across the lauren chen
she is a political and social
commentator all right crosstalk rules in
effect that means you can jump in
anytime you want and i always appreciate
it
uh steve let me go to you first in new
york um the numbers came out a few days
ago cable's down dramatically all across
the board
60 minutes is down 60 uh since the
inauguration of the current president um
and a lot of people are explaining it
because it's trump is gone
and this is what was inevitable i think
it's a lot more complicated than that
steve
i think a lot of people realize that uh
the cable
networks just simply have contempt for
most of the audience that's why people
don't watch it anymore go ahead steve
well yeah uh to an extent although
uh you could have made that argument you
know it's not like we're talking about
years ago
the decline uh 45 50 60
year to year uh in in in many instances
uh so it's it's not as if but this is
something that people
are are you know or have have been
noticing for a long time and it's been a
steady drop off this is a steep decline
and the only commonality here is that
donald trump is gone
look when when you make the president of
the united states
into a villain into hitler call him
hitler
call him a villain call him a murderer
call him mentally unstable
every name in the book i mean that's
going to appeal to the trump haters
and that's why they tuned in now that
that's gone
and they treat according to the media
research center they did a study
and in the first three months of the
biden administration
they have provided 59 positive coverage
to joe biden
yeah with 90 negative coverage
to trump so people don't like good news
or no news or boring news
and that's why they're going to other
places yeah i wouldn't even call it news
but we'll go back to that point because
it's not
news anymore here lauren i mean i i want
to kind of extend my question to steve
here
i mean i absolutely agree with what he
had to say but
the liberal networks demonize donald
trump okay i didn't watch it i didn't
find it interesting i didn't find it
helpful i found it divisive okay and
this is what we have right now
but as an extension to that they were
showing their contempt
for half the country and it and they've
done this at their own peril because
you can demonize the president he's a
public figure a fair game
but you you you demonize the the the
public the public is your audience and i
think that is a mistake and people are
not going to forgive that
because if you're called to deplorable
over and over and over again and what's
the point in tuning in
i watched some of it because i have to
but it's painful for me
go ahead in montreal i'm in the same
position as you the only time i ever
watch something like cnn or msnbc is for
content so i can respond to all the
ridiculous things that they're saying
but you're right that the public in
general knows that the audience
or sorry that the press does not like
them does not respect them and that's
why we see
huge partisan divides in the amount that
people trust
the press and we see republicans and
independents overwhelmingly do not trust
the press it's really only the liberals
that still do and i i mean i i don't
mean to sound disrespectful to
to them but i think a lot of that is
probably because they're reinforcing
their already existing biases that yes
trump is evil the evil right wingers are
just racists who are coming to
round up migrant children uh but you
know like your other guest said that
this trend
this decrease in cable news viewership
has been going on for a while we have
people like in my generation who are
cord cutters
i don't own cable if i do watch a cable
network it's actually online through
streaming or on demand
but i you know the the mainstream media
had a little bit of a bump with
president trump like you said a lot of
that was fear driven and now that he's
gone it's kind of ironic because
through all of their negative press
coverage of trump they
they definitely contributed to his
ousting and i think they were happy
about that on an ideological level but
now they're left with i i suppose not
much to report on since they can't go
after biden
in the same way that they did trump
because that's not politically
acceptable so i think what we're going
to be seeing now
is this shift to other issues that they
are hoping can rile up their audience in
the same way we're going to see them
trying this
for climate change for covid uh you know
before immigration was a great one they
would love to focus on but now the
trouble with that is they can't make it
into a crisis because oops
then it means uh joe biden and kamala
harris are responsible for that so i'm
interested to see in what kind of
boogeyman they
they conjure up in the future well
lauren i think the problem let me go to
rob right now the problem is they don't
report
news that's what i find very very
irritating i don't get my news
from any of these stations including fox
okay i get my information from other
sources and it's online
and lauren i don't even own a television
and i work in television okay
it shows you how uh plugged in i am into
these things here
you know rob the the you know i said the
the the the networks were divisive i
mean and so was fox
okay i mean um always going to back for
him which
i i thought you know is it just because
they're reacting to the liberal media
though that's not good enough for me and
that is not journalism so i you know i'm
putting
fox in the same box as well here because
you know we have to be given the news to
make decisions here not just be pumped
up with anger and that's what
all this media is about it's all anger
and and i think it's getting
worse you know people say people are not
as interested in politics no that's not
true they're just as interested
they're just going to other places go
ahead rob
well first of all i'm glad that you
brought up fox because i think this
isn't just msnbc and cnn
fox is to blame as well and so is
newsmax contributor to both of them
the problem is we don't have real
journalism anymore that's mine i think
we have young people in positions who
don't even understand
what journalism is because they don't
have any boots on the ground and part of
it
is we don't have the old kind of
reportage that we once had
because there's no money really to
support old-fashioned print journalism
where you really researched and covered
a story
but when i wrote my columns for various
publications
i went out and actually spoke to people
on the streets with my notebook
that doesn't happen anymore so where are
we we're at a level of tone deafness
where
it's like this is what we think is
important msnbc
this morning on morning joe they're
still covering january 6th and donald
trump
and and the eruption at the capitol as
if it happened yesterday
people don't want to hear about this and
they don't want to hear about most of
the things
that that cable news is proselytizing
they're out of touch
with their viewers so the viewers aren't
watching just like the oscars
if people don't want to hear something
they just click the button on their
remote and turn it off
okay steve you want to go ahead steve
jump in yeah it's not only the young uh
reporters and people and
and and people in charge executives in
charge of these places
lester holt i mean said the other day or
a couple of weeks ago
you know i don't we don't have to give
both sides that's overrated
you know some things that that that's
not part of journalism anymore
and he just admitted he admitted what's
been going on for
years and years and years and by the way
they do have a boogeyman the boogeyman
of the police
and they pray for riots and they they
poke purposely so division
and blow up every legitimate police
shooting i mean for crying out loud a
cop shoots a
black girl stabbed about to stab another
black girl like this
and racist racist racist it just doesn't
end
yeah you know lauren the the the problem
i have
is that you know we have the russia gate
bounty gate
ukraine gate i mean nothing was there
there was never
anything there and the the level of
trust i mean these people
don't even apologize they won't even say
yeah we got that one wrong i mean they
said yeah we got the iraq rock
war wrong but you know they didn't learn
anything at all okay
i mean again another reason why should
you waste your time
watching this type of thing it's just
affirmational who should i hate today
go ahead lauren no and it is frustrating
especially like you mentioned the whole
russiagate fiasco i mean if you look at
where there's actual evidence of genuine
corruption i'm talking about the hunter
biden barisma you know ukraine scandal
there's zero reporting on that so i
think there's an actual place
for journalism in today's political
landscape for exposing truth and really
do
really doing investigative work but what
we see is that it seems like the most
popular cable
news shows are actually the ones who
kind of lean more into
commentary and punditry i'm talking
about the tucker carlson's and the
rachel maddows people who don't
make their biases uh secret they wear
them proudly and i i'm all right with it
i would rather people
who are in the media come out proudly
and say yes these are my pre-existing
biases this is my opinion
and anything i say is obviously going to
be subject to that rather than people
like cnn
who pretend to be unbiased when really
they're just as partisan as everyone
else
you know lauren i i'm glad you mentioned
tucker carlson because i watch tucker
every time i i really like his program
you know why i like him more i don't
like rachel maddow because you never get
an opposing point of view tucker makes
it a point to bring on people with
different points of view
rob let me go to you i don't know if
you're aware of jimmy dore but he's had
tucker carlson's had jimmy doron a
number of times and you couldn't get
polar opposites more
okay and that i get even though both are
very opinion driven
they they parlay i miss that parlay
because i like to disagree with people
because i disagree with most people on
tv
but some are sharper than others go
ahead rob
yeah i i think that what we've lost is
the opportunity
for discussion on cable news it's more
glad
handing in backslapping or bringing on
somebody with such
an opposite polar opinion that you
humiliate them and make them look like
an idiot
so if whether it be fox or cnn
i'll often see somebody come on and
they'll say this person is representing
this issue and i i don't think that they
are
one of the as i said i used to be on so
many different shows and
i'm pretty much a centrist so i'm not
that valuable anymore because i have
too many same points of view no i might
you know somebody said to me recently
well then you're not really a democrat
why because i don't follow a strict
party line and adhere to every single
thing
that the democrats say there's a lot of
idiotic democrats out there there are a
lot of foolish republicans i don't like
and i'm a you know they don't want that
opinion anymore
and and i think that's wrong you you
should have some crossover
uh viewership and that's why people are
that's why these
all these cable networks are losing
viewers yeah well i think
you know but you know but rob to
reinforce your point there's just as
many stupid republicans as democrats on
cable
okay and it really drives me nuts
because i want to be discerning
okay i don't want to follow a tribe and
i think we
viewers should be educated to think for
themselves or i'm going to jump in here
we're going to go to a short break
and after that short break we'll
continue our discussion on the mass
media estate with rt
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter level to
remind you we're discussing the mass
[Music]
media
okay let's go back to steve in in new
york um you were talking about boogeymen
in the first part of the program
steve i have a new one for you okay the
capitol hill riot slash what they call
it
insurrection i think it's going to be a
star trial i think a star chamber
is going to be a big big deal that's why
the doj asked for extra time
because they're desperately looking for
something but of course they will find
something on somebody somehow related to
those
uh to that uh event okay and again
it seems to me this is an intentional
division of the public here instead of
trying to understand what went
wrong because something very bad
happened
it's it's to start pinning blame and
it's all it's all about trump it's still
all about trump he's not in the public
eye but
75 million people that voted for him are
go ahead steve
oh yeah and and i think the justice
department is gonna wait until uh it's
near election
time so they could portray all
republicans and blame all republicans
as they did remember any uh elected
official
who brought up the election and
questioned the election results
was as guilty as those who invaded that
capitol building
trump was guilty for the big lie that
was the new big lie
uh and you're absolutely right uh when
it comes to uh trump
they're never gonna stop there'll be an
attempt i think trump will face some
kind of charges somewhere some grand
jury will indict
him i think they're waiting for this and
waiting uh so that they could uh
capitalize on doing the most damage to
republicans when the
midterm elections come or maybe the next
presidential election
look there is so much here to report on
if they wanted a report
on what biden is doing do you know we've
redefined every term racism
everything is now racist i was going to
say to rob you're lucky you're not
called racist
for not being a true democrat and
agreeing lockstep with them
they'll call everybody okay well there
you go
and how about also uh now bipartisanship
did you know it's no longer bringing
along people for legislation republicans
and democrats
it's what the polls say that's the new
definition of bipartisanship
and it goes on and on and on and the
media is silent they accept it nobody
questions it
there is no more journalism that is
totally dead dead you know lauren
there there was a public opinion poll
that came out that uh biden has like
what 52 53
approval and then we have on i think it
was msnbc saying
well 53 means um uh no
that's the new 60 here i mean if that
isn't
gaslighting people i mean i mean
actually i if you thought about it
clearly
and the history of the polls over the
last two cycles
if i hear 52 i think it must be 36
okay because that's what logic would
dictate okay but but still
we have this gaslighting you're
absolutely stephen pointed it out here
i mean no criticism whatsoever you know
there are plenty of things to criticize
trump for and i wish people would have
done it on fox
there were things that i agreed with
fine but you know
you have to distill these ideas and not
lie
march in lockstep and this is what's
continuing to happen
and it's tearing the country apart where
the people
do not trust each other the americans
who do americans fear most
other americans go ahead lauren you're
right and it is
shocking to see how the media is really
thriving and sowing this division and
you know black lives matter is an
amazing uh
sign of this right we have tons of
americans who go on the street and riot
and cause violence and destruction
and the reason why they're doing that is
because they are honestly being fed the
idea
that the police will gun them down for
no other reason
than their skin color i mean imagine put
yourself in the in the
position of someone who really just
believes everything the mainstream media
says
if you actually genuinely believed that
police in america were just going and
shooting black teenagers for no reason
wouldn't that be cause for some sort of
upheaval
of course it would be but the thing is
that is not the case but the fact that
the mainstream media
is is trying to convince people that it
is four ratings i think makes them at
the very least complicit in all of the
damage and destruction
that has been done and the same is true
for right wingers as well
i obviously do not condone what happened
on january 6th but i think the reason
why people felt compelled to take that
action is because
again they lost trust in the system i
mean we had big tech censoring anybody
who wanted to question
the election results we had mainstream
media ready to call anyone a conspiracy
theorist or
a foreign asset or whatever it may be if
they didn't
agree with the narrative so there's like
again this amazing gaslighting that is
happening and i find it especially funny
that
you know the the left is trying to make
this huge uh mountain out of the
molehill that was the january six events
even though we now know that uh officer
brian sicknick did not die as a result
of any
violence from that day they're not
really talking about that as much
yet they've been relatively quiet about
all of the black lives matter
destruction
of all the antifa riots in portland
there's a huge double standard
well lauren peter go ahead before you go
to go ahead jump in
the poll that you cited the 52 approval
in the washington post poll for biden
at this 100 days that's the lowest going
back to truman
except for trump and ford that's the
lowest
so that is huge news considering that
the media is trying to prop him up the
way they are
and you would think that that would be
news
yeah but but steve it's the new 60 okay
i mean go ahead rob jump in go ahead
let's we can put politics aside and go
into health
and and and human welfare which is
none of the cable networks are really
effectively covered covet as far as i'm
concerned
you know that i speak a lot about i'm a
spokesperson for the american heart
association
the american diabetes association and i
tried to get on so many shows i got on
one or two
it was never wanted to be discussed but
the fact that
americans are unhealthy that's one of
the reasons kova ran so rampant here
two-thirds of our adult population are
obese one-third morbidly so
but do you ever hear that discussed no
are we doing anything proactively
to try to change that no has the media
ever reported it no not really they
really want to instead talk about the
all the people that are dying
not why yeah well rob thank you very
much
for saying that it's a real public
service because you know
i'm sick and tired of it being used as a
cudgel to go after this governor
this mayor this news outlet it doesn't
do anything for the public good
whatsoever and you know what as a result
of that nobody knows what
really to think about it anymore all you
do
is get it's a cudgel to go after your
enemies instead of
actually caring about the public good i
mean it's really infuriating to me
and you know and i live in a different
country i live in russia the reaction of
it is completely different
and i watch my own country of birth and
why you guys all
chasing yourself with this okay it's
just
you have to deal with it you hunker down
get used to it and it'll pass
okay it's not a political weapon in most
of the world
it is in the u.s go ahead look at that
immediately
go ahead lauren good well you're right
not only are we not talking about how
uh being overweight is a huge
comorbidity for most of the fatalities
that have happened but instead we
actually see the press
trying to spin this into a tale of
racial division
there have been numerous stories on
places like cnn or bbc
about the racial divides in covid
fatalities and now it's actually gotten
so bad where you have places like
california
and canada where people who are not
white are being prioritized
for vaccinations because there's this
whole narrative now
saying that covid is either a racist
virus in and of itself or our society is
just so racist that we're actually
making non-white people unhealthy
and it's just a gross example of how
something that should be non-political
like just
general general health and welfare of
the american people it's now become a
politically charged issue and it extends
to mass mandates and lockdowns
as well well lauren and then you have an
open border with people coming in with
covid but
you can't you have to live in your
garage if you live in michigan i don't
get this kind of thing you know steve
you know it's already been mentioned
here you know if you disagree with the
the narrative coming out of the liberal
media you're a conspiracy theorist
but what have they peddled for the last
five years
one conspiracy after another
demonstrably
provable that it was okay i mean
this is this this projection drives me
nuts i mean
it would be funny because uh because i
can see through it in a heartbeat but
it's a lot of people believe it go ahead
steve oh
absolutely when the entire media uh on
the left and that's that's that's the
majority of the media when they're
putting forth this narrative
and you have hearings held on this
narrative and you impeach the president
on this narrative
you know i mean and you have former
officials come on these cable shows many
of them get hired
by these cable shows and networks um
pushing this narrative
that contributed to the high ratings is
something we should certainly point out
and and that's a it's a bunch of
propaganda but look what's worse now is
that being called a conspiracy theorist
i think we really have to focus in on
this
you are a racist you are racist if you
don't believe
that uh that this virus
disproportionately uh affects blacks and
and people of color
because of our uh inequalities our
history of racism
uh the and equity this new push for
equity every other word out in gensake's
mouth at the white house press briefing
is equity this and equity that and
equity
is racism steve what the hell
is it what is equity what is it
okay you keep hearing it yeah it's
giving
people things to put them equal to other
people
and what it comes down to is giving
black farmers reparations
uh in the uh in the stimulus bill and
not giving any to white farmers
it's giving the shots to black people
people of color and putting the white
people at the back of the line
it is reverse racism and the media is
loving it you know you know rob you know
i'm going to surprise a lot of my
conservative friends because
when i look at a lot of this coverage
here you know you playing the race card
all of the time it's exhausting it's
stupid and it's
simply not true the real issue is a lot
of inequality in the united states are
just
there's a lot of poor white people too
and i
one of the things that really bothers me
is that you know you have the
the cable news kind of um empire
and they don't collectively they don't
want to talk a lot about inequality
about class differences
race issues are very easy to peddle and
it's usually 25 year old
editors that graduated from a very
expensive college that got no education
at all
at the end of the day and they write
this nonsense they're not looking at the
real problems in the country go ahead
rob
there's a great quote from the filmmaker
werner herzog
the world reveals itself to those who
travel on foot
and how can you be a journalist or call
yourself that
and not set foot outside and have your
boots on the ground
and talk to people if you do that which
i still do
you're you're going to understand you're
going to be connected to the public
mindset and
these idiots aren't they're sitting in
an office somewhere or even worse now
all alone in their home or apartment
just opining
uh and it's it's just really a tragedy
as far as i'm concerned
well i mean at the end of the day these
people they just talk
to other people within their bubble
what's really terrifying is that half
country doesn't know the other half
and the other half doesn't want to know
the other half and then
and it is the result of a media that
does this okay
and they do it for ideological and for
um a profitable reasons
it's profitable for some we'll see where
it goes that's all all the time we have
want to thank my guests
in new york and in montreal and i want
to thank our viewers for watching us
here at rt see you next time and
remember
crosstalk rules